we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p you can call any time of day
here's someone who's very angry with me
for my sort of real world view about the
upcoming election well David I see that
you've fallen into the two-party prison
now you know convinced me that Hillary
Clinton would be any better than Donald
Trump or even different than Donald
Trump but you know it seems as if it's
the same agenda it just puts on a
different mask every four years yeah uh
okay I mean I fallen into the two-party
trap I've sort of made it very clear
that all in all along I've been pushing
for the best possible thing I could
which was supporting Bernie Sanders
right now I don't want to take any
action that helps Donald Trump become
the next president that's where I am
Louis if that's falling into the
two-party trap will I guess I fallen
into it and nobody else has and I'm the
problem I don't know on the bonus show
today huge follow up from our hot dog
story from yesterday very interesting
audience anecdotes about that we will
also talk about New York City giving
dead people tax exemptions and some
Prince Edward Island monks have bought
six hundred pounds of lobsters to
release into the wild probably to be
caught again is my sense but we'll talk
about that on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership is how you
sign up and get instant access to the
members only bonus show